In this video we will talk about the size of the cells
and in particular how small they can be,
and what factors they determine
how big they can be.
Here are some photos of cells.
Here's a picture of Pseudomonas bacteria.
Each of these pill-like things
is a bacterial cell.
And to have an idea of ​​what scale it is, the width of this pill
is about one micrometer.
So that's about one micrometer here,
which is equivalent to one millionth of a meter.
Or one thousandth of a millimeter -
Choose what helps you imagine it better.
The length of this cell is about 5 micrometers.
This is approximately 5 micrometers.
Here I have pictures of cells from the human body -
red blood cells.
They have a diameter of about 7 micrometers.
Both white blood cells are of similar magnitude.
Let's look at something else.
Here we can see a human sperm that will penetrate at any moment
in a human egg. Human eggs
are one of the largest cells,
especially among the spherical cells.
This cell has a diameter
in the order of 100 micrometers.
It's very cool, that
all these pictures are on the same scale
so you can compare them to size.
The first question we have to ask is how small a cell can be.
He thought: the cage is a living organism
and it's actually quite complicated.
She must have information, she has her DNA, she must be capable
to divide - has all these metabolic mechanisms.
I recently read that the smallest cells observed,
and why not the smallest cells at all,
although in the future perhaps even smaller cells will be found,
are about a few hundred nanometers in size.
Do not forget that the width of this pill is 1000 nanometers,
so several hundred nanometers would look like this.
300 nanometers - this is the size of the smallest cells,
known to science at the time,
which are bacterial cells,
found at the University of California, Berkeley.
We think their size is pretty close to the lower limit,
because, remember, we have to keep
all genetic information and cellular mechanisms.
All this is complicated and it would be harder for the cell to be smaller
But how big could it be?
One of the factors determining the maximum cell size,
among other factors,
is the ratio between volume and area.
Why is the ratio between volume and area important?
Because the surface of the cell connects it
with what is around it.
The surface is responsible for the intake of substances and the separation of waste products,
so each unit of the area has to process
incoming and outgoing substances
for a certain volume of the cell.
As we will see later, with the growth of the cell
its volume and area do not grow evenly - the volume grows
faster than the cell area.
The larger the cage, each unit area
must process substances
for more and more volume.
At one point, he can not cope with this task - he can not take up nutrients
and to get rid of unnecessary products quickly enough.
And to imagine it even better,
let's think about this from a mathematical point of view.
Let's imagine that this is a sphere here ...
wait for me to draw it a bit three-dimensional.
If its radius is r, its volume will be (4/3) πr³.
Its area will be equal to 4πr².
Let's now calculate the ratio between volume and area,
because that's what we really care about.
The area will be in yellow, so the ratio between
volume and area will be equal to (4/3) πr³ on (4/3) πr³.
Fortunately, we can easily simplify the liver.
4 divided by 4 lines 1, divided by π makes 1,
r³ divided by r² will be simply r,
and so we get r / 3.
If we look at the units of measurement, we are actually talking about
cubic unit volume or cubic unit volume
on square units.
Which makes r / 3.
We will use this to see what is happening,
when the cell increases its size multiple times.
For a simpler, let's focus on this white blood cell
and to facilitate the bills, let us assume,
that its radius is 3 micrometers.
I'll use a different color to make it clearer, 3 micrometers.
In this case, the ratio between the volume and the area of ​​the cell
will be 3 micrometres divided by 3,
which, of course,
makes 1 micrometer.
Unit of 1 micrometre for area volume
it does not make much sense.
An equivalent unit would be 1 cubic micrometer
per square micrometer because we divide the volume of the area
and it is clear that if we cut the units
and we make a large-scale analysis,
this micrometer will remain.
This helps us to imagine it even better,
because it means that every square micrometer
has to deal with a cubic micrometer cell volume.
So the square micrometer for this cell
will be about that size
and will have to process
an average of one cubic meter of volume.
It seems acceptable
and indeed this is acceptable for cell size.
But what would happen if we increased its size 1000 times,
increasing the radius of the cell 1000 times?
Obviously, the scale is not the same as for the previous cell,
but let's say we find some new organism or think of it,
whose cellular radius, instead of being 3 micrometres,
(this was 3 micrometers here) would be 3000 millionth of a meter.
Keep in mind that this is not a huge amount from a human point of view,
but is equal to 3 millimeters.
It could be seen with the naked eye, as the human eye
can distinguish between objects up to one tenth of a millimeter,
making 100 micrometers.
This is approximately 1/10 of a millimeter.
Under favorable conditions, you can hardly see a human egg.
This cell here
we would not have thought it too big, but let's see what's going on
with the ratio between volume and area.
3000 microns divided by 3
makes 1000 micrometers,
or 1000 cubic micrometers per square micrometer.
That is, every square micrometer
must process a cubic micrometer volume.
Now, however, we have not one, but 1000 cubic micrometers,
that is, a much larger volume.
The cell will fall apart because it will not be able to
to exchange gases, nutrients and waste products
fast enough to function.
So the volume-area ratio
is extremely important for cells.
When the cell grows,
the ratio between volume and area or mass is interesting,
very many ratios are interesting
and this is just one of them.
The other factor that matters
when increasing the size of the cell, are the long distances,
through which substances are transferred.
This could also slow down the processes in the cage.
But the relationship between volume and area is the reason why,
which is why they rarely meet
very large spherical cells.
I emphasize the spherical cells,
because there are very long cells,
such as nerve cells.
They manage to compensate for their large size through various adjustment mechanisms.
One of them is just to be extremely thin and long,
so this is one of the mechanisms that allows them
to make the most of their area.
This is a nervous cell.
Another such mechanism
is the presence of appendices,
which have the same function.
In short, not all cells are spherical
and have other adaptation mechanisms,
thanks to which they can use the maximum potential of their area.
There are various such mechanisms, but the representation of the cell
in the form of a sphere is not strange
and this is the reason why no cells are found
much larger than a human egg.